IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
TONIGHT STUNNING NEW REVELATIONS
ON ANTI-TRUMP BIAS OF THE FBI.
AS YOU KNOW, TWO AGENTS REMOVED
FROM THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
EXCHANGED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
TEXTS, MANY DISPARAGING
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING.
ACCORDING TO TWO LAWMAKERS,
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE ALSO
ELECTION.
>> THE DAY AFTER THE ELECTION,
WHAT THEY REALLY DIDN'T WANT TO
HAVE HAPPEN, THERE IS A TEXT
EXCHANGE BETWEEN THESE TWO, FBI
AGENTS, THESE TWO SUPPOSED TO BE
THE FIRST MEETING OF THE SECRET
SOCIETY.
OF COURSE I'M GOING TO WANT TO
KNOW WHICH SECRET SOCIETY ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE INVESTIGATING
OBJECTIVELY THE PERSON WHO JUST
WON THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
I'M GOING TO WANT TO KNOW.
>> Kimberly: FIVE MONTHS WORTH
OF TEXTS BETWEEN THE PAIR HAVE
GONE M.I.A.
THE FBI LOST THEM.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED AT ONE OF
BUT HERE'S ONE THAT WASN'T LOST.
IT SHOWS STRZOK EXPRESSING
SKEPTICISM OF THE MUELLER PROBE
WOULD UNCOVER ANY WRONGDOING BY
THE PRESIDENT OR HIS TEAM.
SENATOR SANDERS WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S THOUGHTS ON
THESE DEVELOPMENTS MOMENTS AGO.
FIVE MONTHS WORTH OF TEXT
MESSAGES HAVE GONE MISSING,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE
INDIVIDUAL PART OF THAT PROCESS
HAS ALREADY BEEN SHOWN TO BE
WHAT SEEMS TO BE SOME VERY
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR.
THAT CERTAINLY IS OF GREAT
CONCERN.
>> Kimberly: OKAY, SPEAKING OF
SECRET SOCIETIES, CLEARLY THERE
IS ONE BETWEEN DANA PERINO,
MYSELF, AND SARAH SANDERS IN
SHADES OF PINK AND PURPLE.
>> Dana: JUAN IS AN HONORARY
MEMBER.
>> Juan: I GOT THE MEMO.
TRYING TO MATCH GREG'S HEAD.
>> Kimberly: LOOKS BETTER
TODAY.
STRONG STATEMENT FROM THE AG AND
MENTION OF A SECRET SOCIETY.
ALL OF IT HAS COME OUT IN LITTLE
PIECES.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CONTEXT
IS AND THERE ARE PEOPLE PUSHING
A PARTICULAR AGENDA THAT MIGHT
SAY WELL, THIS OBVIOUSLY MEANS
THIS.
IT COULD MEAN SOMETHING ELSE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
I'VE BEEN AT THE WHITE HOUSE AT
A TIME WHEN THERE WERE EMAILS
THAT WERE ON A SERVER THAT WENT
MISSING.
IT'S LIKE THERE WAS A TECHNICAL
PROBLEM.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHERE THEY
WERE, AND IT CAUSED A HUGE
HULLABALOO FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY ULTIMATELY WERE FOUND.
THE FBI HAVING THE TOOLS IT HAS
PROBABLY WILL BE ABLE TO FIND
THEM.
RICHARD BERG, SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN,
SAYS HE DOESN'T THINK THERE WAS
MAYBE THAT'S TRUE, MAYBE NOT.
I DON'T KNOW.
THEN YOU HAVE THE TEXT YOU JUST
READ WHERE STRZOK SAYS I DON'T
THINK THERE IS ANY "THERE" THEY
ARE.
SEEMS TO SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT'S
POSITION THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
IT'S ALL OVER THE MAP.
I'M GOING TO WAIT TO MAKE ANY
CONCLUSIONS UNTIL THERE IS SOME
SORT OF CONCLUSION BY EVERYONE
ELSE.
>> Kimberly: JESSE, ARE YOU
>> Kimberly: I'M GOING TO DO
THE OPPOSITE OF DANA AND NOT
WAIT FOR ANY CONCLUSION.
I'M GOING TO MAKE MORE OUT OF
THIS.
IT LOOKS TO ME LIKE THERE IS A
ROGUE FEDERAL AGENTS TRYING TO
CORRECT THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
UNDERMINE AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
IF YOU HAVE FBI AGENTS TEXTING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT AFTER TRUMP'S
ELECTION AND YOU HAD A SECRET
SOCIETY BETWEEN THE FBI AGENT
AND JUSTICE OFFICIALS WHO WERE
THE SAME PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
THE ELECTION OF DONALD TRUMP,
THAT SEEMS PRETTY SKETCHY TO ME.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOW WORKING ON THE MILLER
TEAM BEFORE THEY WERE FIRED.
ALSO THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AND
COUNTERESPIONAGE AGENT ON THE
FBI WAS TAPPED TO BE IN THE
"THERE" THERE.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THAT SAYS A LOT.
THAT'S HIS JOB.
THAT'S HIS WHEELHOUSE RIGHT
THERE.
HE GETS PUT IN THAT POSITION.
THEY DON'T REALLY FIND ANY
WHO IS THE CHIEF WITNESS FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE?
JAMES COMEY, THE BEST FRIEND OF
ROBERT MUELLER.
COLUMBIA TO BE HIS PERSONAL
LAWYER.
THEN THE FBI TEXTS GO MISSING?
THE INTELLIGENCE FROM A CRITICAL
TIME PERIOD WHEN THIS
INVESTIGATION BEGAN?
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
TODAY THE CHIEF OF STAFF OR
JAMES COMEY IN THE CURRENT FBI
DIRECTOR RESIGNS ALL OF A SEVEN.
I AM WILLING TO MAKE A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF IT THEN DANA PERINO.
BUT SHE HAS ALWAYS BEEN MORE
CAUTIOUS.
>> Kimberly: JESSE MAKING HEY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> Greg: I AM GOING TO TRY TO
MAKE AS MUCH SENSE AS POSSIBLE
WHICH MEANS I WILL MAKE NO
SENSE.
I ENJOY THE SCANDAL PING-PONG OF
THIS.
EVERY TIME SOME ENTITY PUSHES
THE RUSSIAN OCCLUSION NARRATIVET
THE RUSSIAN OCCLUSION NARRATIVEE
FBI, DOJ COVER-UP COMES RIGHT
BACK.
AND IT FEELS GOOD AT THE MOMENT
BUT THEN THEY END UP ALL WET.
THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU.
THE TEXTS BETWEEN THESE TWO
AGENTS, IT DOES REFLECT WHAT WE
REACTION.
PEOPLE HATE DONALD TRUMP AND
THEY STILL DO.
THEY FEEL JUSTIFIED IN DOING
ANYTHING BECAUSE THEIR SENSE OF
RIGHTEOUSNESS MADE IT OKAY.
GAVE THEM A GREATER PURPOSE.
YOU THROW INTO THAT THE ROMANCE
OF IT.
THEY ARE IN LOVE.
YOU CAN HEAR DAVID BOWIE'S
"HEROES" IN THE BACKGROUND.
IT'S TWO AGAINST US.
SECRET SOCIETY.
I GO BACK TO MY PLACE OF WISDOM,
IN THE HOUSE.
IT'S TRUE.
THEY PLAYED BALL IN THE HOUSE
WITH THEIR WORK PHONES.
THIS CONSPIRACY STUFF EXISTS
BECAUSE IT CAN.
AMERICA IS A RESILIENT COUNTRY.
THE ECONOMY IS BARRELING ALONG.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON AND ON
ABOUT THIS.
IT'S ALMOST AS THOUGH THE MEDIA,
LIKE WE ARE WATCHING A NETFLIX
SERIES WHERE WE ARE ALMOST DONE.
BUT THE MEDIA IS STILL STUCK ON
THE FIRST EPISODE.
THEY CAN'T MOVE ON FROM THIS
STUFF.
THEY ARE SPINNING THEIR WHEELS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T LET GO.
DON'T PLAY BALL IN THE HOUSE.
>> Kimberly: SEEMS LIKE YOU
HAVE GOT SOME ENERGY.
YOU ARE DOING BETTER TODAY.
>> Greg: THANK GOD FOR
MEDICATIONS.
>> Kimberly: BUSINESS AS USUAL
FOR GREG GUTFELD.
JUAN, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> Juan: BREAKING NEWS ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
NOBODY MENTIONS IT BUT
APPARENTLY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WAS INTERVIEWED BY ROBERT
MILLER.
OH, MY GOSH.
BY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
NOT ONLY THAT, JIM COMEY
INTERVIEWED BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
APPARENTLY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS BEEN PRESSURING CHRISTOPHER
WRAY, THE FBI DIRECTOR, TO GO
AFTER ANDREW MCCABE.
TRUMP NOMINEE, THE TRUMP GUY AND
FBI SENT TO THE TRUMP
ATTORNEY GENERAL IF YOU WANT
THIS DONE, GET SOMEBODY ELSE IN
HERE.
HE DIDN'T SAY HE WAS GOING TO
QUIT BUT HE SAID HAVE SOMEBODY
ELSE DO IT.
OH, MY GOSH.
WE HAVE A PICTURE HERE OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW
ON ITS HEELS.
INVITING TO DISCREDIT THE FBI
AND ROBERT MUELLER.
MEANWHILE, MUELLER'S HAVING
STEPPED STEPPED-UP ACTIVITY AND
IT'S DRIVING NOT JUST TOWARDS
THE POSSIBILITY OF COLLUSION BUT
TOWARDS OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
AT THIS MOMENT, WHAT DO YOU GET?
A COUNTERATTACK FROM THE TRUMP
STOOGES ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> Greg: STOOGES?
>> Juan: IMAGINE THAT.
TWO PEOPLE HAVING AN AFFAIR,
TEXTING EACH OTHER.
PEOPLE INSIDE THE FBI HAVE
OPINIONS ABOUT ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS AS IF THAT IS NOW
UP.
IT >> Greg: COLLUSION ONLY
MATTERS IF IT'S SOMEONE YOU
DON'T LIKE.
WILL IGNORE ANY REAL COLLUSION
IF YOU LIKE THAT PERSON, YOU
COLLUSION.
THAT LYNCH KNEW AHEAD OF TIME
THERE WERE THOUSANDS OF TEXTS
LOST AND THERE'S A SECRET
SOCIETY BUT THAT IS NOT
COLLUSION BECAUSE YOU LIKE
HILLARY.
>> Juan: KNOW, IF IT WAS
SOME DEMOCRATS ARE CONCERNED
>> Greg: OF COURSE THEY ARE.
>> Juan: IN THE MIDST OF THE
ARGUMENT OVER THE DACA PROGRAM,
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS DIDN'T
CARE ABOUT RUSSIA DURING THE
COLD WAR.
NOW THEY CARE?
WHEN IT REALLY MATTERED, WHEN WE
ARE FIGHTING THE RUSSIAN
COMMUNISTS, THE DEMOCRATS WERE
CAVING AND APPEASING.
NOW WHEN RUSSIA IS NOT A THREAT,
ALL OF, ALL OF A SUDDEN.
IT >> Juan: I SAY JESSE,
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, DO YOU TRUST
HIM?
>> Jesse: I TRUST ANYONE HE
HAS EMAILED AND TEXTS.
WHERE DID THE TEXT GO?
>> Kimberly: ALL RIGHT.
>> Juan: SCREAMING IS NOT
EFFECTIVE.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT DEFENDING
ANYTHING.
>> Kimberly: TO DANA PERINO.
>> Dana: A LOT OF SMOKE COMING
FROM A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
WHERE THERE IS SMOKE THERE IS A
LOT OF DIFFERENT FIRE.
PEOPLE UNDER INVESTIGATION ALL
THE TIME.
FORMER GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE
FOR EXAMPLE.
THINGS CAN HAPPEN ALONG THE WAY
BUT THE INVESTIGATIONS TAKE A
LOT OF TIME.
AMERICANS TUNE INTO THE NEWS
BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST
ENTERTAINMENT NOW.
WE EXPECT SOMETHING NEW EVERY
DAY.
I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE
THESE DIFFERENT ENTITIES WHICH
IN ONE NARRATIVE.
OH, YEAH, IF YOU'RE GOING TO PUT
UP THE THING ABOUT THE MISSING
TEXT, I WILL PUT OUT THERE THAT
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
INTERVIEWED THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
>> Greg: THEY ARE ALL EQUAL.
THEY ARE ALL, LIKE, PROS AND
CONS.
THEY NEED TO HAVE A LOST AND
FOUND FOR MISSING TEXTS.
SOMEBODY HAS TO INVENT THAT.
>> Dana: I THINK THEY WILL
PROBABLY FIND THEM.
>> Greg: THE SIZE OF A SMALL
CAR.
>> Dana: THEY DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY ARE MISSING.
THEY HAD 50,000 THEY REVIEWED.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT THERE WERE
50,000 MISSING.
I SHOULD PROBABLY READ MORE
CLOSELY.
>> Dana: IT COULD BE 100,000